oh hey Keith can you tell me something  good about mom was she like she was  always helping us out  do you think she still remembers you  look around the show anybody watching  over your arms just us we don't serve  your time here Blackie  nah a little kid your family I don't  think you understand I'll come back work  doors open genius why are you painting  around a place anyway  Hoover thank you guys Sloane in the  timberlands I see this is what the sale  and discount  there's only emotion to you people at  you and me so we only got any talk sighs  you're gonna have to wait a few years  play a little nippy candle in the wake  of the Rodney King jury verdict I've  ordered the Justice Department to help  restore order in Los Angeles know where  they mean I'll go in Korean it just  means country  [Music]  and not your family  [Music]  my window pane  [Music]